(upbeat electronic music)
- Welcome to Ear Biscuits, I'm Link.
- And I'm Rhett.
This week at the round
table of dim lighting,
we are exploring the
question how do we deal
with a medical crisis and
let me just say first of all,
we're both fine.
Neither one of us are
personally in a medical crisis.
- Right.
But--
- This is something
that happened to Link--
- Over the past week.
- Not personally but, personally but--
- I have been dealing with
a family medical crisis
which I'd love to just be able
to verbally process through
with you, gentle listener, as
well as you, gentle friend.
- And I don't wanna--
- Gentleman.
- I'm not trying to spoil anything here.
- But we should--
- This person that you're gonna be talking
about is fine now.
- Yes.
- 'Cause we're gonna be having fun.
This is gonna be also light-hearted.
- Yeah.
- We're gonna talk about
some serious things that
happened but we're also gonna be
having a good time joking
because in the end,
everything is okay.
Well this is what happened
and I'll walk through the
details and unpack it.
- Well first we gotta let people know,
we're gonna keep telling you--
- Oh about our dates.
- Educating you about
where we're going to be.
We are coming to a town
near you if you happen
to be in Las Vegas, we're
gonna be there on June 21st,
Salt Lake City June 22nd, Denver the 23rd,
Milwaukee the 25th, Indianapolis the 26th,
Detroit the 27th, Omaha the 29th,
and Minneapolis on the 30th.
Again this is Rhett and
Link live in concert,
not the Tour of Mythicality
and debuting, well, if you've seen 'em,
there's some new songs that
have never been heard before
on the internets and then
of course the old classics,
the rap battles, there's
potential dress-up that happens.
- Dress-up, that is a good way to put it.
- Anyway, it's--
- We play dress-up.
You buy a ticket, we play dress-up.
- And there's also VIP tickets available.
Of course you're all
very important people,
that's just the industry
vernacular to describe someone
who pays for a ticket where
we get to have a little meet
and greet so all that and
more at RhettAndLinkLive.com.
- Come see us, RhettAndLinkLive.com.
So in some ways I am
still very much processing
what happened over the past week.
And it involves my mom's husband Lewis
who I've talked about many times.
He's technically my step-dad
because he's my mom's husband
but he's not my dad.
- He's your step-dad.
- That's what I just said but
I've never actually ended up
calling him my step-dad.
I'll end up saying something
like he's my father-in-law
if I'm pressed.
- Which is incorrect.
- But because--
- And strange.
- He married my mom, I
mean they were dating
when I was in high school, you know,
I've known him for a
long time and I love him.
- But he didn't raise you.
- I do love him but he didn't raise me
and I never lived with him.
So I got married and
then Christy was pregnant
with Lily and that's when my
mom and Lewis got married,
so there's an interesting
dynamic to the nature
of our relationship that
I love him, but he's not,
he is my step-dad but
I don't call him that,
in the experience it
just doesn't feel like
what a step-dad feels like.
- And actually I think that
my mom's husband is the correct--
- Well that's true too.
- No I know but--
- Father-in-law.
- If I meet a--
- Is not correct.
- If I meet a person,
if I'm just at a party and
I'm having a conversation
with somebody and they
begin telling me a story
and they say my mom's
husband, I immediately know,
oh not your step-dad,
your step-dad is somebody
who you usually would
say raised you, right,
but father-in-law, you
gotta stop saying that.
- But father-in-law--
- 'Cause what's gonna happen
is you're gonna be seen
with him in public at some
point and they're gonna be like
oh that's your father-in-law,
no this is my father-in-law.
Then you're one of those
guys that has two families,
one being secret.
(Link sputters)
And you can't be one of those guys.
- Well, I mean I do have a secret family
but I have nothing to do with this.
- I will say that Shepherd asked me...
There was something in the car
and when he got into the car
the other day and he was like,
"Where's this from?"
I said, "Oh that's, one of
the kids in my secret family
"left it in here." (chuckling)
I just couldn't help myself.
- Hopefully you meant imaginary family.
- I said, "You know Locke,
"a lot of people have a second family."
- So don't joke about it.
Oh I thought you said this was Shepherd.
You said Locke.
- It was Shepherd.
- Oh you just said Locke,
you meant Shepherd.
- Okay I meant Shepherd
the whole time, anyway,
I joke like that with my children.
They know that it's a
joke so get off my case.
- But was he joking when he
told you is the question?
- He didn't tell me.
He said, "Where's this from?"
and I said, "It's from--"
- Oh you said that.
I messed up.
- I think everyone else
understood, I don't know if
I said it in a confusing way
but I'm sorry if I did.
- So confused.
So anyway, Lewis, my father-in-law.
(chuckles)
That does come into the
story later, by the way.
He's doing well now but he had,
I don't wanna
over-sensationalize it but...
- Well then just sensationalize it.
- I'll just say but I do think
it was a brush with mortality.
Brush with death.
It took some time for that to sink in
and so I'll unpack that, like I said,
some of this I'm still processing
but he gave me permission
to talk about it here
and take it for what it's worth.
My mom and Lewis, they
came out here last year
and then we visited for Thanksgiving
and then that's the last
time we've seen them
in person so they kinda
wanted to come out again.
But they've got a house,
they've got farmland.
He drives around his farmland on his Gator
and he surveys his land
and he sees turkeys
and he keeps an eye on how
many turkeys will come around.
- And for those of you
who don't understand
what a Gator is, it doesn't
mean he's on an alligator.
He's on, it's like a John Deere
crazy off-road golf cart kinda thing.
- I kinda wanted the mystique to be that
maybe he's just saddled
an alligator but fine.
- Well if you wanna believe
that, yeah, go ahead.
- Clear up the mystique.
He's got cows.
Mom named some of them and
then he takes care of 'em.
They have babies,
they make sure that
everything's good to go.
Basically he has a farm to run.
- Right.
- So it's hard to get away
and they're not the traveling type.
So we planned this a long time in advance
and I think Mom came down with something,
they had to reschedule one time.
Something came up, I can't remember.
But then weekend before
last they were coming out
and they were gonna show up Friday night
and then they like to stay
in a hotel, not at our house
so we make 'em feel comfortable
whatever way they want
and then they were gonna fly back Monday.
- That's a quick trip.
- They were only staying
two days.
- Those cows.
- They gotta get back to their cows.
- Somebody's gotta look after 'em.
- And we were very much looking
forward to making the most
of those two days.
So we pick 'em up at the airport,
the whole family's in the car
and we're crammed into there
and we pick 'em up at the curb
and I can immediately tell that
Lewis is road ragged,
he doesn't look great.
I'm like man the flight
must not have been great.
They get in the car, put the luggage in
and we're driving them, it was late so
especially by their time
so we just went straight to their hotel.
- Did you say anything at that point?
Did you say, "You look awful."
You shouldn't say that to someone right
when they get off of a plane.
I've made that mistake.
- Did not look good but I was like,
"Well how was the flight?"
And they said it was okay.
- A lot of turbulence?
- Lewis didn't have much appetite.
They didn't say much about
turbulence or anything like that
but he was very quiet and
you may have heard me talk
about this before but the thing
we love to talk about Lewis
is that he's got this catchphrase.
Good, good, good, like if
he's talking to the kids,
the whole week leading up to them coming,
I'm talking to all the kids and I'm like,
I'm talking like Lewis, I'm
doing my impersonation of him,
like Lincoln, you been
doing your push-ups?
How's basketball?
And I'm like Lincoln, you're
not playing basketball anymore
so you gotta be ready for your answer
'cause you know Papa's gonna
ask you about basketball
and your push-ups.
- You might to just make up--
- [Link] You've not been doing either.
- [Rhett] That you're
still playing basketball.
- So he has his answer
prepared and I was like,
you can just tell him that
you're mountain biking
with your dad and you're
still staying active
and then he'll just
say, "Good, good, good."
- (scoffs) Giving your kids answers.
- (chuckles) Just trying to coach--
- Just let them come up
with their own answers, man.
- But we were looking
forward to that catchphrase
and I couldn't help
but notice he was quiet
and there was no good,
good, goods happening
on the ride to the hotel.
- But he wasn't saying, "Bad, bad, bad."
- He was not saying--
- It doesn't go that far.
- No and I took a wrong turn and me
and Christy kinda snapped
at each other a little bit.
- What about the GPS?
- Well you know how when
sometimes your phone's hooked up
to the cords and then
the map's not showing up
on the car play and I'm having to drive
but I can't see the turn,
and now I'm going the wrong
way and I'm getting angry
and I gotta direct that anger at somebody
even though my mama's in the
car and I haven't seen her
in person since Thanksgiving.
I'm not gonna direct it
towards my mom or Lewis.
So Christy got a little bit of that,
she gave it right back.
- Good.
Good, good, good.
- Good, good, good.
I deserved it and then so
I thought that the silence
might have been as a
result of me being an.
- Right, okay.
- We get to the hotel, we
check 'em in, they're tired.
We let 'em go to sleep, I was like,
we'll come pick you up as early
as you want in the morning.
You're on east coast time.
Well, Mom never called
so we finally called
by mid-morning and she's
like Lewis is not doing well.
He's feeling faint and he's passing blood
when he uses the bathroom.
And I'm like well,
not good, good, good.
- No, mm-mm.
- So we come, we pick
'em up and we're like,
we go straight to the emergency room.
- Now explain that
decision to me because--
- Well when you're passing blood--
- Well no no--
- You need to go
to the emergency room.
- I'm telling you,
I am the kind of person
that always minimizes.
You know what I'm saying--
- I'm that way too.
This was Christy driving this train.
- Right so Christy, she's
good in those situations.
She has a natural nursing instinct.
I've never nursed her.
(Link sputters)
Just so you understand.
- Great.
- But she has that, she's
good in medical situations.
There's a certain mode--
- She goes into this
ready contingency mode.
When we were going to
sleep the night before,
she was like, now the nearest
hospital where they're staying
in Pasadena is the Huntington Hospital.
- For those of you who
understand the Enneagram,
a six is really well-equipped--
- That's what she is.
- At these sort of
contingency plans.
- So she was like I think
Lewis wasn't doing good
and we may have to take
him to the emergency room.
She already said that the night before
and that's why she was calling Mom.
They checked him in and he was...
I actually don't think
he passed more blood
when he was there and then
it takes awhile to process
and they said we're gonna admit you
because something's going on
here, there's internal bleeding
or there's evidence of that.
And your blood count is low.
They check him in to the
ICU, intensive care unit,
and so they're monitoring him very closely
and one of the nurses said to Mom,
"Your husband is very sick."
I was like well what does that mean?
We don't know yet.
The gastro doctor comes
in and they did a scope
from down his throat--
- Oh man.
- They put him under for a little bit,
we stepped out of the room
and less than a half hour
they did this procedure
where they put the
scope down his esophagus
through his stomach, looking at everything
into his small intestine and
then we come back in there
and he's already awake again.
But the news is Lewis has over 10 ulcers
in his small intestine.
Good gracious, this does not sound good.
- Not the stomach, the small intestine.
- Yeah, the duodenum.
Duo denim.
I don't know how you say it.
- You know if you take that out,
you can stretch it around
the earth nine times.
(Link chuckles)
- Just Lewis's, you know how long his is?
- Yeah yeah, just an individual's.
- Oh okay.
- Mm-hmm.
- That can't be true.
But it--
- That's how quickly
light travels, the speed of
light I think around the earth.
Nine times in a second, I don't know.
I'm confusing facts.
- The doctor gave us the
good news that even though,
I don't know if this is a southern saying,
'cause the doctor didn't say it.
He was from LA, he wouldn't,
but what I would say is,
he's eat up with ulcers,
he's eat up with them.
But he said there was one in
particular that looked bigger
and it had a scab that had formed over it
just like skin on the
outside of your body.
- This is tough to listen to.
- I'm sorry.
I'm surprised I'm able to talk about it.
We can get into that more later
but he said that just like
skin on the outside of
your body on the inside
of your intestine, it forms a
scab with which then it heals.
And he said I agitated the scab.
It's amazing, you put the scope down there
with a camera and take
pictures, you see the live video
and you can blast water
and also medication
through this scope.
- And they can control it like a
(mimics zapping sound) kinda thing,
like once it gets down there?
- It was actually very easy to control.
- You can manipulate it.
- He said, "You wanna try it?"
And then it was like two joysticks.
No I didn't see the thing, man.
We went out, I don't know how
many joysticks there were.
- I'm just assuming
that to be that precise,
it has some sort of mechanical head on it.
- At the moment I was not asking
about the mechanical head.
- Again, that's what I'd
do in these situations
'cause I don't want to
talk about the real--
- You deflect.
- Let's talk about the
mechanics of the machinery
that's inside of him right now.
(Link chuckles)
How 'bout that?
- But he said he sprayed
it with a little water
and then all evidence pointed to the fact
that it was gonna stay which is great news
and it also meant that
if they monitored him
and there was no more bleeding,
that that meant that there
wasn't any other source
of bleeding lower down in
the rest of his GI tract.
'Cause to do a colonoscopy,
to go from the top up,
you have to--
- The bottom of him.
- Yeah from the bottom
up, you'd have to wait
to totally clean out the entire system.
And that was just more time, but anyway,
at that point we were in a holding pattern
and because it's the ICU--
- Because that equipment
is very expensive,
you don't want, all over it.
- (chuckles) Yes, Rhett.
That's exactly what it is.
I'm trying not to be that graphic.
In the ICU, they make everyone leave
while they have shift change.
So just so happens that
we had made reservations
for this Japanese steakhouse
before we knew any
of this was gonna happen.
- Yeah take a break,
go eat some Japanese.
- So we're gonna, you make
me feel horrible about it
but Christy was like
I'm gonna stay around.
- We have reservations, Link. (chuckles)
- Granny, why don't
you go and see the kids
and just take a break
because we're not allowed
to be in here anyway.
- Yeah.
- And it's very close.
- And was it one where they
throw the shrimp in the hat?
- Yeah they throw the shrimp--
- And the fire volcano made of onions.
- I thought that would be nice.
- Oh yeah it's always nice.
- So Christy stayed back,
so she was very much
in proximity even though she
wasn't allowed to be in there.
And then I took Mom,
because we had good news
and we were in a holding pattern--
- Oh so you went to the
Japanese steakhouse.
- I went too, yeah me and
Mom met Britton and the kids
that we met at the Japanese steakhouse.
- Did you get a combo of
chicken, shrimp and beef?
- Yes.
You're deflecting now.
- No, I really am interested
in what people order at that.
I always get the combo.
- And we're all on edge
but it was nice for her
to see the kids 'cause otherwise,
she wasn't able to see them
and I go up to use the restroom
right before he starts flippin' shrimp
and as I'm walking into
the restroom, I look up--
- Shrimp.
- And daggum, if it
isn't the scope doctor.
The frickin' scope doctor,
the gastro guy--
- Oh okay.
- Was at the Japanese restaurant.
- I heard you guys talking about this
but I didn't understand
that this was the story.
- Yeah he was one of those
hibachi guys, he worked there.
- Oh yeah well you know what,
doctors these days
don't make enough money.
- Right.
- You gotta have
a backup plan.
- He was there
with his family at another table
and I went up, I was like,
I found myself upon him
by surprise on my way to the
bathroom so I'm in his face
and I'm like I recognized
him and I'm like,
"Hey doc, you just...
"You were just treating my father-in-law."
- Right, yeah.
- And again, I just came
out with father-in-law.
And it worked.
- Yeah 'cause he doesn't know.
- And he understands that it's not,
I don't know what he
understood but it was easy.
- Right he just got the chicken though
because he's a doctor.
- It was weird 'cause it was
like one of those moments
where remember in, well I
remember in middle school
when I went to Walmart one time when I was
in third grade and I saw Miss
Hobbs, my third grade teacher
in the chips aisle at Walmart.
- And you're like what,
they can be outside of school as well?
- And she started talking to
me and I felt really weird
and I got embarrassed and I was like,
(babbling) I don't know how to talk.
- Did I get grade on this conversation?
- Yeah I felt like a third-grader
in the hibachi restaurant
talking to my teacher.
- Right.
- It was weird.
But he was very nice and he
came over and he talked to Mom
and she was very appreciative
because we had good news
at that point.
- And he's like
you wanna see some pictures of the ulcers?
- He had already shown us those.
- But not at the restaurant.
- Yeah but not right there.
And then I was like, we
brought the kids back
and we took them up to see
Lewis when they allowed us
to go back in the ICU and
the nurse had a funny look
on her face and I looked
around into the room
and Lewis did not look good
at all, he looked worse,
and then the kids said hello
and then it was kinda like,
Christy why don't you just
take the kids back home.
I'll stay here with Mom and
then I'll Uber back later
'cause the plan was we were all leaving
and Mom was just gonna stay but...
It took awhile for it to really sink in,
but what had happened was he
had started passing blood--
- Again.
- And this sounds like a
great place for a teaser.
(chuckles)
- Oh gosh.
- Because we need to do a short break
and let people know, oh things got worse.
- Things get worse before
they get better but they do.
- But we are gonna take a short break
and let you know that
you can get these mugs
we're drinking out of.
You can't get this one.
This was a prototype, I don't
even know why I've got it.
This is just to tempt you
with something you can't buy.
- We prototype all types
of things in order to land
on the perfect thing for
your mouths, your bodies,
your hairs.
- I'm trying to blend in completely today.
As you can see, I have
two different brown mugs,
I have a brown hoodie
on, I have brownish hair.
- Brownish skin.
- It's all kind of blending
in with the background and I kinda think
this might be my new thing.
- What are you selling?
You're having focus issues today.
- I'm selling beigeness.
- That's not for sale.
- It kinda is though, you'll see,
you'll understand what I'm
gettin' at months from now
but in the meantime what
you can buy is these mugs
and lots of other cool things over at--
- Mythical.store--
- Dot store.
- The hindsight of the experience,
it just seems much more clear than when,
when things are progressing
in the hospital,
the nurses and doctors
are reacting to things
and it's not that
they're not communicating
but it's the combination
of them doing their jobs,
trying to communicate but
also the ability for that
to sink in, to be able to
receive the information.
The doctor would just drop in occasionally
and it's go time to have your questions.
- Could you imagine just--
- And that's difficult.
- Could you imagine being the person?
Neither one of us would be good at that.
We might be good at--
- You mean the patient?
- No the nurse.
- Oh gosh.
- Having to do something
but then also explain
to someone in a sympathetic
tone what's actually happening.
Forget about it.
- One of my big takeaways
from this thing is
I have just a blossomed appreciation,
specifically for nurses
in a hospital environment.
They are amazing people who
do an amazingly difficult job
and that's a big part of it,
interacting not only with the patient but
with the loved ones who are there present.
And for me I'm bringing my kids,
one of my kids is too young
to actually be there and
I'm breaking the rules
for him to come up so--
- Really, what's the age limit?
- 14, in the ICU.
- And they let you do that?
- Well yeah, a 14 year old
but not a nine year old.
- No but you were able to get Lando in.
- I just kinda went up with him.
- Oh.
- 'Cause I was like,
Lewis is fine and his
spirits will be lifted
by seeing you for a minute.
That was not smart, I should
have respect that rule.
The nurse actually told
me he could see things
in the ICU that--
- He will never forget.
- A nine year old may not want to see.
- Will be etched on his brain forever.
- I was like wow, I'm an idiot
and you really made a good point.
I'm gonna take my kids out of here now.
My head space was so,
this is gonna be over at any moment.
This is gonna be okay,
we already got good news.
Yes he has ulcers, yes he's
gotta figure that stuff out
and there's gonna be
more treatment to come
when he gets back home.
But he's in the clear.
When we got back, Christy
took the kids away
and they had already been giving him blood
because he had lost blood--
- Already.
- The night before.
I think by this point,
they were giving him six,
seven, eight pints of blood.
- Whoa, whoa, whoa, already.
- I'm telling you.
I was there, this was 10 o'clock at night,
11 o'clock at night, midnight, and then--
- 'Cause you don't have that much,
I told you about this recently.
- Yeah for the book we had to,
oh you don't wanna say that?
- Well no, okay...
I had to look up for a part
of the book we're working on
how much blood is in a human body.
- Yeah, and what's the answer?
- I think the average adult just has
like two gallons of blood.
- Well how many pints is that?
- I don't know.
- Three pints in a gallon?
- Hopefully more than that.
- Four, I thought there was
only four pints in a gallon.
- All I'm saying is--
- Kiko will look it up 'cause we're stupe.
- There's a lot less blood in a human body
and so giving him that much blood,
like he didn't have hardly any.
- Well and then the thing is,
he was confined to the bed--
- What is it, Kiko?
- Eight pints to a gallon.
- Eight pints
and then how many, you said
there were how many gallons
in a body?
- Like two gallons of blood
in a body.
- So 16 pints.
- Look that up too, I wanna make sure.
- How many pints of
blood in a average body.
'Cause I will say by the end of this,
they gave him 12 pints of blood.
How many?
- 12 pints, so that's, wow,
so about a gallon and a half
of blood in an average person.
- But I'm telling you right now,
they gave him enough blood
that fills up a human body.
- That's crazy, that's what
so surprised me 'cause--
- Yes and the more it, and again,
they kept giving him, when
they were giving him two,
three, four, five,
concerns start to raise, my man,
and they said okay,
we're gonna to have to
give him a central line.
We can't use the IVs to keep
up with him passing the blood.
And it was a very visceral experience
which he doesn't remember
any of even though
he was conscious, he was talking,
but he wasn't very lucid.
- Yeah.
- As you can imagine.
- Right.
- And in that situation,
you can't move him out
of the bed and he's passing blood.
It's a visceral and horrible situation
to be bedside for that.
- Okay this is coming from the guy who,
you can't take any amount of blood
and the thought of needles,
and they're sitting there
filling your father-in-law.
(chuckles)
- Yeah just fillin' him up.
- With, I mean how--
- He's like a fountain,
it's just passing through him.
- Did you go into a mental space,
like a un-before-tapped,
never before tapped mental space in order
to get through this without fainting?
- Earlier on whenever
he started passing blood
and they would clean him
up, I would step out.
But I felt like that was
just to give him privacy
and for them to do their job.
- So you were--
- And then I would
come back in, and I was in a zone.
- You were in a mode, a zone.
- I guess I was in a zone of,
it was kind of a...
It was a bit of a fog.
It was not realizing how
dire things were getting
but then when they said we
need to give him a central line
in his neck so that we can pump blood in
and keep up with how
quickly he's losing blood
and we're getting the doctor back in here
to do another scope in order to see
where this new bleeding is coming from.
- Well just goes to show you not only
how important blood is.
- Yeah.
- There are these places, there
are so many places on earth
that don't even have adequate
amounts of clean blood.
- Yeah, and yeah.
- Privilege just to be in
a place that you can lose
that much blood and immediately
have it replenished.
I don't know what the PSA
is here but give blood.
- I thought about that too.
- And also be willing to take blood.
I don't know there's some people--
- There was never a
conversation about that.
- Well I know but--
- There are people who--
- If you currently subscribe
to a worldview that doesn't
allow you to take blood,
reevaluate that world view.
- Well he would have died.
- That's my second PSA.
- He would have died
within a few hours we get
to the hospital, he wouldn't
have anywhere close to this
if he couldn't take blood.
They couldn't find a central
line in his neck that worked
and they had to do a
central line in his groin
and then basically his hip.
And then they're pumping him full of blood
in order to just gain time
and it was at that point
that I realized that
oh my gosh, this is--
- Serious.
- This is very dire.
This is touch and go.
- How's your mom handling
this at the time?
- She was in more, I wouldn't
call what she was in a fog,
she was in more of a supportive,
she was very positive.
And she was going to work in
terms of just being positive
and in support mode, it was--
- And she come from--
- It was amazing.
- She's come from a
medical background being
in like a clinical place.
- Yeah, she took blood for a living
and she's used to being around blood
and medical environs.
- Yeah.
- So she wasn't shaken up
by that but she said later
that it dawned on her the next morning
how dire things were there.
I just think that she was in a mode
where she wasn't allowing
herself to go to the dark
potentials, okay.
- The dark potentials.
- That's the name of our second novel.
- But the doctor finally showed
up and they got ahead of it,
the bleeding a little bit but
it was scary because there
was blood all over the bed.
- Mm.
- And they couldn't keep up with it
so they would put a blanket
down over him and...
He was disoriented so at
times he would look down
and he would move the blanket
and he would see all the blood
or he wouldn't see it and
his hand would go down there
to feel what's going on.
- This is tough for me
to listen to, I'm sorry.
- I guess the reason--
(Rhett sighs)
The reason why I share it is because
I think...
I could never imagine
that I would be bedside
for a situation like that with my mom
and I'm glad that we were
able to be supportive
but it was very scary and
I never would have thought
that I would have been able to be,
to contribute to a supportive environment
when it was that scary.
- Well just, okay--
- So I'm surprised, I'm not bragging.
I'm just saying that these things happen
and maybe you go in a mode
but if you don't,
I feel more prepared
having gone through it
to be more supportive--
- Well I do think that,
I will say that the human
brain is really complex
and I think that what ends up
happening a lot of times is
you know that you can't
afford to check out.
I think there are certain
situations where you can afford
to check out, like when you
cut yourself at Christmas,
it's like it's not that big of a deal.
- And faint into your
real father-in-law's arms,
which I did.
- But my question is,
why were you the one that was there?
It was just circumstances
because of the way
that you brought the kids in and then,
you didn't know how bad it was gonna get.
'Cause if you think about
how bad it was going to get
and Christy and you both knew
and you had to make a
decision who was gonna stay,
you probably would have
picked Christy to stay
and you would have gone
home with the kids.
Or was it because it was your relations?
- Yeah it was because, Mom, well...
I'll back into that 'cause
I do think it's interesting.
I feel so much and I felt
so much for Lewis and Mom
because they don't travel
and then they find themselves
going through this
situation so far from home
with no support structure
beyond me and Christy.
- Right.
- They know no one else
except they might have met
people in passing through us
but there's no one, like back home,
Lewis has an extended family
that they're very tight-knit.
So his real name is Edd, I
think Lewis is his middle name.
Edd with two Ds, and then the hospital,
they kept asking him, "What's your name?"
And then in order to give
medication or do treatment
or just know if he was lucid,
they would ask him his name
and they were expecting him to say Edd
and he would say Lewis so they would think
it was worse than it was
but his brother, Edd.
He's got a brother Ned, Ted, and Fred.
- Yeah it's unbelievable. (chuckles)
- And you better believe they
all would have been there
as well as his children and
everybody else who loves him
and obviously would have
been there to support him.
- Ned, Ted, Fred and Edd.
- And Peggy.
- Yeah there's not a
good typical woman name.
- They call her Ped.
(Rhett chuckles)
No they don't.
There may be other siblings,
I can't remember, but anyway,
because they're out here,
it's just me and Christy
with Mom to, we find ourselves
in this weird situation
where we're the only
support that they've got
so when we had to send the
kids, I was like, well,
Mom's gonna stay there for Lewis
and I'm gonna stay there for Mom.
I'm gonna support Mom and
Mom's gonna support Lewis
and then honestly that's the first way
that I thought about it.
I think that changed over that
night and the next few days
but we can talk about that some more
but at this point, yeah, we
did actively make that decision
for me to be there with
mom and so by 1 a.m.,
the doctor's showing back
up and doing the scope
and finding that that
problem ulcer was basically
at this point, obviously gushing blood.
- Ugh (winces).
- And then to use that same scope--
- You gotta put a trigger
warning on this episode.
(chuckles)
- I think maybe I'm able
to talk about this in a way
that maybe I feel
differently about blood now.
- Well but you're also the one saying it
so it's not happening unexpected.
- He's able to use that scope
in his hibachi hands.
- Right, he's still got
chicken grease on him.
- And he sprayed some epinephrin.
- You think he put the
redneck sauce on his chicken?
- He puts redneck sauce on that ulcer
and it just sutures right up.
- The creamy sauce that you
can get at the hibachi place
we always call--
- Redneck sauce.
- Because only, you go over to Japan,
they don't have that sauce, okay.
That's something rednecks came up with.
- It's good.
- Now it's good. (chuckles)
- I took the whole bowl that night
and I just poured it all over my plate.
I was like--
- I'm a redneck.
- Yeah.
I could feel my mullet growing.
(Rhett chuckles)
So he--
- Epinephrin.
- He put some epinephrin on it
and it's basically sutured it up.
- It's a vasoconstrictor.
- And then--
- Who knew?
- And he showed us, well he did.
And he showed us pictures of it.
And I'm thinking, man, I saw
you at the frickin' hibachi,
at like seven o'clock.
- Yeah you can't be here.
- And now it's 1 a.m.
and you're here.
- Right.
- And I'm in third grade, it's so weird.
That was excellent news but
as we were waiting for him
to do the scope, Mom and I had to step out
and just wait and it was like
we were sitting in the waiting
room just the two of us,
no one else was in there.
And we didn't say a word.
We were so exhausted.
- It's like somebody who's
been through a battle,
you just sit there.
- You just sit there
and it was very surreal.
And she told me that it
really hadn't sunken in
at that point how dire things were,
she was in that mode and...
We're kind of in fight
mode, stay positive mode
and so at that point
it was very touch and,
the great news was they
found the bleeding,
they had stopped the
bleeding, they didn't have to
do a second procedure which
could have damaged the kidneys
in order to try to find the bleeding
or a third procedure worst case
where they had to do surgery.
The surgeons were coming in
and prepping him for that too
in case they had to.
It was that, everybody was buzzing around
and it was, yeah, it was very kinetic
and it was real, man.
And by that morning, he had
stabilized and of course,
he wasn't given any drink or food
for probably the next
48 hours as it turns out
but they were monitoring--
- They were hydrating him intravenously.
- Yeah.
- Or else he would die.
- And giving him medicine for the ulcers
and giving him medicine to help,
to preserve them from bleeding
and giving him more blood.
To come out to a total
of 14 units, 14 pints.
- So again,
he replaced his blood supply.
- Yeah.
- He completely replaced his blood supply.
- Wild.
And so then--
- Everybody needs that.
It's just like changing
your transmission fluid,
every once in awhile.
- That's literally what happened.
But they didn't drain him
out and then fill him up,
it was a constant flow, it was more--
- Yeah, you can't do that with a human.
- It was a nightmare.
- You can do that with a car.
- It was an absolute nightmare and then,
so then for the next two
days it's kinda touch and go
to make sure that he's not bleeding
and even though he's not eating,
then as you slowly introduce
drinking and then eating foods,
clear fluids and all that jazz.
It's just continue to monitor
that he's not bleeding.
And let's see, so we checked
him in Saturday morning.
We checked him out by the end of the week
so he was there a whole
week so then it was,
it basically shifted
from emergency situation,
he left the ICU to a regular hospital room
which then you and Jessie
came that first night
and visited him there which was great.
But then it was just, that's
when it really started
to hit us that
there's only three people to
support him in his recovery
as he's here and that proved to be
very challenging because my
mom stayed there all night
and then as soon as I could
get up in the morning,
I would go and relieve her.
Either Christy would come
get her or I'd send her home
to my house in an Uber to take a shower
and try to sleep for a few hours and then,
Christy and Mom would
come and then I would go
into work for a few hours and then
so someone was always there
with him for the whole week.
And I really gained an appreciation
for how important it is
to have people come visit.
When you guys came that night to visit,
it was a tremendous
help and something that
I never appreciated when it's like,
someone's in the hospital sick,
well you should go see 'em,
you know, you should go see 'em
because it's the right thing to do.
But I never really connected
the dots that for the people
who are actively supporting
the person in recovery,
it's also a huge help to them to,
you run out of stuff to talk about.
You run out of, it
drains all of your energy
to sit in a hospital room.
And when doctors and nurses are comin' in
and just constantly pricking,
prodding and doing stuff,
it's not a happy, it's
not Disneyland, you know.
- No and as a matter of fact--
- My takeaway.
- We were there for a
very short period of time,
but first of all,
I got lost.
I had a window of time
between leaving here
and then going to therapy
and I had kinda planned
to have half an hour
and Jessie was gonna meet me.
But my frickin' GPS, my phone, sent me to
the back of the hospital.
- Yeah and it's a big hospital.
- And I parked and then I had to,
I was like 20 minutes from my car.
And then I walk into the
lobby, the hospital lobby,
and I see you checking
in and you had left work
like way after me.
- Oh yeah.
- And that's when I see through the window
and I see the thing I had been
looking for the whole time,
the grand hospital entrance.
There's multiple doors and
there's a big horseshoe
where you kind of drop
people off and I saw Jessie
and I was like, "Where'd you park?"
She was like, "I valeted." (chuckles)
- Yeah she went to the right entrance.
- So yeah I got lost.
- And I'm so sorry that
happened to you, man.
That's kind of like
having a bleeding ulcer
and almost dying.
- Yeah yeah yeah.
But what I was getting to is how much
I was just reminded how
much I hate hospitals.
Now, I appreciate hospitals.
They're absolutely necessary.
But I get, and this is
probably something a lot
of people relate to, it's
like, I've never been
in a hospital personally,
like I've never had
to go to the hospital for anything.
- Mm-hmm.
- I've been to the doctor or
have had very small procedures
at a outpatient clinic.
But never been in a
hospital and when I go into
a hospital and on the
floor that Lewis that on,
you had to pass by several
rooms that were open
and these people are in
different states of disrepair.
- Yeah.
Sometimes there's screaming.
- Well there was one guy who was having
an interesting exchange with a nurse.
- Yeah, there's interesting
scents that float about.
- And again, I don't know what it is.
I was going to therapy right after that.
I didn't get into this but I don't know,
I just get this feeling that I'm just like
I don't want to be here and I don't want
to be a patient here ever.
- Yeah and you feel like
being here might make me sick.
I think things like that.
But--
- And there's people
who have to spend not just--
- Oh gosh.
- We met the kids at
St. Jude who basically,
some of them have spent--
- They live there.
- The majority of their
lives in that environment.
And places like St. Jude
do go to incredible lengths
to create an environment that is not,
it's not depressing other than the fact
that why you're there.
- Yeah and this hospital
was a great facility.
There's no actual criticism
that we could level
on the facility or the
faculty at any point.
It's just, it's more about
the stigma associated
with hospitals or the fact
that a hospital is still,
it is what it is and it's
not a pleasant environment.
- And it's way more pleasant
now than it was, what--
- Oh gosh.
- 50 years ago or whatever.
- I mean all the procedures
they were doing on Lewis,
they would cart the stuff into the room
and do the scope and everything
there, it was amazing.
I was talking to him later.
We were watching Leave
It to Beaver one morning,
I was like can you imagine back in the day
if Beaver had some bleeding ulcers,
what would they have done?
- He would be dead, they'd bury Beaver.
- They just would have
done surgery in order
to find where you were bleeding, I think.
- Mm-hmm.
- There's no scoping in your
room and 30 minutes later,
your wife can walk back
in and get good news
and a picture of it.
- It's all conjecture.
- But I was, I gained
such an appreciation,
like I said, for the nurses
and hospital staff in general
but also a revived sense
of how important it is
to visit people in the
hospital and not let the way
that we instinctively think about it,
like I should visit but I'm not going to,
it makes a huge, huge difference,
and when you guys came,
you lighten the mood, have
somebody else to talk to,
pass a little bit of time.
And obviously also give
and receive love and care.
It can't be understated
but for some reason
in my mind I think it
had gone to that place
and you know what?
In a few days we're comin' up
on the two year anniversary
of Lily having her spinal fusion surgery.
As we record this it will
be this coming Friday
'cause I've put it on the calendar.
Two years.
And I'm a little discouraged
that I'd forgotten
what I'd learned there,
the things that I'm now talking about.
Because in her recovery
how important it was
for people to come and offer support.
And again, I just felt
for Lewis and for Mom,
especially Lewis because
his family wasn't there
and it was an interesting
situation because
I'm in a position where I'm
spending hours with this guy
that I've never spent,
I'll ride on the Gator
with him and the kids down and
see the cows and come back,
but it's not like the two of
us have a vibrant relationship
where we hang out.
I love him because he loves
my mom and my mom loves him
and they are very happy together
and they have a beautiful relationship
and they're perfect for each other.
That is enough for me
to love him unabashedly.
But it--
- The Gator helps.
The Gator helps.
But when it comes to the
experience of a relationship,
it was an interesting position to be in.
For him and for me probably.
Where we have to assume
the role of the people
who are providing the
only emotional support
for hours at a time.
And I really had to deal just honestly.
This is not about Lewis and my
relationship with him really,
I think it just kinda set the
stage for me to think more
about my level of selfishness.
Honestly a lot of that came up because
I just realized how much
I want my life to be
ordered the way I want it to be.
Well they're gonna come in for two days,
this is our itinerary, we're
gonna have a really good time,
and then they're gonna leave
and get back to their cows
where they wanna be and
everybody's gonna be happy
and I know what my next
week has in store for me.
And I'm looking forward to it.
It's a light week at work.
I was looking forward to specific things.
- Mm-hmm.
- We weren't filming anything so it was,
that was actually a blessing because I--
- Yeah.
- And again, I actually,
with all the stuff that
we have going on at work,
I actually had a week where pretty easily
I was readily available
to support in a way
that I very much needed to be there.
- Which is very unusual.
- Yeah, and I'm very grateful for that.
I would like to think
that I would have made
the right decision to
change whatever I was doing
in order to be there anyway.
But I don't know if I would
have made the right decision,
because I was still wrestling
with the selfishness
of my plans, my life, my time,
my desires, my comfort, you know?
Again, it's embarrassing to talk about
but I feel like that's part of my takeaway
in terms of my growth in this situation is
what really is love in this situation?
It's making a decision to be there.
Aspiring to be better at
loving somebody that I do love
and knowing that I just didn't,
that I had so many
competing personal desires
that were just lame, you know?
Sure, yeah, it's difficult
to go through that.
It's difficult to hang out at a hospital.
It's difficult to know what to talk about.
But really, these are things
that in your own brain
you would complain about?
- Well I think everybody,
I think most people would.
There are some people who are naturally,
my wife being one of them,
naturally equipped to just,
she can walk into the
hospital room with Lewis
and she A, she knows exactly what to say.
- She knows what to say
and she knows what to do.
- And she could talk to somebody forever.
I come in and I'm like,
"Welcome to California."
I make a joke, right?
- Which is helpful but yeah it's kind of,
I relate to that 'cause
it's like searching for
how did I get myself in this situation?
- Well and a lot of times--
- I don't know what to do here
and my instincts don't apply.
- Well and I've actually,
in many different ways,
this is one of the
advantages and I don't know,
advantages and disadvantages
of being married
to someone who complements
you in a certain way, right?
Who has a characteristic, for me,
I can just be like, oh,
Jessie is really good at that.
She knows what to say, she
knows how to comfort somebody,
so the unit of Rhett and
Jessie can comfort someone
because Jessie will do
it because I can't do it,
and for me, it's part
of what you're saying
which is just like well I got
too much stuff I gotta get to.
My stuff that I gotta worry about's
more important than this,
there's part of it that's that
and then the other side is
just feeling inadequate.
- And also what happens
when the comforting aspect
of the unit is the one
that needs comforting?
(chuckles) It's like it
kinda breaks down internally
at that point too, right?
- Yeah, that's when you hire someone.
- (chuckles) Oh shoot.
- No, yeah, exactly.
That's where it becomes,
it's not a good thing.
I'm saying you end up creating
a, your deficit can grow
because you're relying
on someone to fill that.
- And I learned so much
from Christy to be able
to meet people's needs and have empathy.
I guess that's what we're
talking about, right?
We're talking about being empathetic.
- Yeah, I think that's a part of it.
- And again, that's why I'm so in awe
of people who devote
their lives in the field
of nursing and all the people who would,
the people who come in and clean the room.
The assistants to the nurses,
everybody who have devoted
their lives to caring for people
in that way is just...
It's amazing.
And it draws into focus ways
that I can kinda step up
and be a better person, I think.
I think in watching those people and
dealing with the patients
and even in the moments
of frustration and in
confusion, just having composure
and still having...
Just bringing healing to
a situation is something
that I don't know, my eyes
were really opened to that.
Lily's situation was different
because it was a planned procedure
and it was a controlled recovery
that we were prepared for.
So there was never any huge
scrambling emergency moment.
I think that's the difference here
that then there were ugly aspects to it,
to this experience that
I witnessed firsthand
people stepping up and
helping.
- Well and what it makes me
think about is people who...
Lewis, he's home now, right?
So it was an incredibly
difficult week full of lessons,
but what if the second week
was just like the first week
and the third week was
just like the second week?
And people who have their
lives turned upside down
because someone becomes
critically ill, terminally ill,
like if it happens to
somebody in your family,
if it happens to one of your children,
then all of a sudden your
life basically becomes
what you're talking about.
- Mm-hmm.
- And that is, that
becomes your new normal.
Which again, I'm gonna
keep plugging St. Jude.
I didn't expect to but
they helped us understand--
- Right.
- All the support that a family needs.
They have a program at St. Jude
that is specifically designed for siblings
of terminally ill kids and
because what they've seen is that
these kids, they have emotional needs too.
- Yeah.
- And when all the attention
and all the resources are going
on this person who is sick,
what happens to you?
I think in the book and the movie Wonder,
they talk about the older sister's story.
Anyway, all that to say St. Jude is sort
of like love in action.
You're talking about what
you can do personally
and they've kinda created a whole system
to support that kind of love in action.
- This experience I think is,
it's just kinda jostled me awake to my
unwarranted expectations
that my life is gonna be,
continue to be what I expect it to be.
We experience so much positive things
and it's like, in this conversation,
you start to feel a
little guilty about it,
but it's not that I wanna feel
guilty, I wanna be grateful.
But I also want not to live my life as if
I expect or demand
no curve balls, you know?
- Well yeah.
And we talked about this before.
There are many times when
things are going well
and I think both of our personalities
are actually geared towards all right,
kind of expecting something to go wrong.
Because things shouldn't,
things are going well right now
so surely the bottom's
gonna drop out somewhere
and sort of just anticipating that
something like that will happen but also
at the same time knowing I
am not emotionally prepared
and I am also not, I am
also too selfish right now
to be able to take this,
something that would
inconvenience me to that level.
- Yeah.
I'll share one more image,
something that I wanna,
a memory that I wanna stick
with me I'll share with you
in order to help solidify
it since sometimes
maybe saying stories
helps me remember them
or at least now I'll have an audio record.
Oh gosh, we must have been three days in.
They had started allowing him to drink
and eat some liquified foods
but then they had evidence
that he might have been bleeding again.
It was kind of a panic
mode for a few minutes
and then they pulled,
well not a few minutes,
but longer than that,
they decided to pull back
and he's not allowed to
eat or drink anything
as they monitored him.
Now it turns out that he
was not bleeding anymore
but that was a setback in
terms of his experience.
You're confined in a hospital
on the opposite coast
with me supporting you every
morning alone. (chuckles)
No, he was very gracious
but it was very frustrating
to not even be able to drink water at all.
It was tough to keep his spirits up
and the television helped.
I know at home, he falls
asleep to the television on.
That's like his white
noise so that helped him.
It gets him rest, and then,
but the thing that
happened a few hours later
after the step backwards,
not being able to even drink anything
and him literally being parched.
The television went just to fuzz.
(mimics static crackling)
And I look at it.
He didn't say a word but
I'm thinking oh my gosh,
this is like the main
thing that feels like
holding us together now
is just the television.
There's no food, there's
nobody else but me to talk to.
And now the television is weak signal.
It said like signal cannot be acquired.
I'm like oh crap.
And then I'm panicking
inside, I'm trying to put
on a positive face and I'm
like, well, what do we do now?
And then I stood up and
I look at the television,
kinda like when you open
the hood of your car
when you know something's wrong with it
and you're supposed to look at the motor
before you decide to get
someone who's qualified
to fix it, I'm like, uh, I'm
gonna look at the television.
What do we do now, and
so I'm standing there
at the foot of the bed
and then I was like,
"It looks like I'm your
only form of entertainment."
And then I just started doing,
I guess I'll call it an Irish jig.
It was kind of a Riverdance thing.
There was some elbow movement though
and a lot of leg movements
and some kicking.
- How long did that last?
- 'Til I got winded.
'Til I got a smile out of him.
And then I was like,
"Do you have any cash?"
He said, "No, I don't have any.
"I don't know where my
wallet is," and I was like,
"Well, then I'm not gonna strip for ya,"
and then I got a laugh out of
him and it was the first time
he had laughed, I don't
know, since before he landed.
And then so that helped,
but then I ended up
unplugging the television
and doing all sorts of religious
ceremonies in my own brain
and plugging it back in
and it started working.
So we got Leave It to Beaver back on
and some Price Is Right.
And then they started introducing,
allowing him to eat,
drink water, and then,
eat these Icees, like lemon ices.
But he had been talking
about these lemon ices
'cause they had let him have 'em
and then they took 'em away.
And then a whole day later,
he's talking about these lemon ices.
- Anything at that point.
- Oh gosh.
It was like a mirage in
the room, I felt like.
And they finally told
him he could have one.
And I brought it in there and
this was like a culmination
of like hours and hours
of being fixated on it
and then he had this
lemon ice and he's eating.
I'm like, "How's that lemon ice?"
He was like, "Oh.
"It's good, good, good."
(Rhett laughs)
And I said, "What did you say?"
He said, "I like that lemon ice."
I was like, "No, what did you say?"
And he said, "It's good, good, good."
(Rhett laughs)
And I said, "That's exactly right."
So I'll never forget that.
- Now what happened to the cows?
- They're fine.
- What happens when you--
- His brothers and some,
he had someone else
who helps with the farm
to help with the cows.
- Was it Ted, Fred, or Ned?
- I don't know, probably all of them.
The cows were taken care
of, we got 'em on a plane,
his daughter picked 'em
up, drove them home,
they got home that night.
It was 10 o'clock at night
after a long day of traveling
but he was doing fine.
Evidence being right when they got home,
they took their luggage in the house
and then Alison, his
daughter told Christy,
took the luggage in the house
and then he immediately came back outside,
grabbed the leaf blower
and started blowing off his car port.
And then the next morning
he got up and he said,
he was going out the door and Mom said,
"Well where you going?"
He's like, "I'm gettin' on the
Gator, I'm going out there."
She said, "Well you can't
go out there without me.
"I gotta get ready."
My mom,
she likes to take her time to get ready.
- She takes awhile to get ready.
- Well, she likes to take her time.
- Well, okay.
- Let's just say
it's a choice.
- I'm just saying
I remember it from my childhood.
(Link chuckles)
- And he was like, "No,
I'm going out right now."
And she said, "Well let
me put on my house coat,"
and then she was telling
Christy, she was like,
"For the first time ever, here
I am in just my housecoat,
"driving around out here in the Gator."
- Can't let the cows see you.
- And then, so he surveyed
his property, came back,
parked the Gator, went inside,
sat down in his recliner
and Mom said that was the
first time he seemed 100%
at ease in over a week and a half.
- Yeah, he was back in his environs.
- Yeah so he's doing well,
he's got to tackle these ulcers
long-term and figure out,
and they're gonna monitor
that and they're gonna figure,
they're gonna get to the bottom of it.
- They're getting to the
bottom of why it's happening.
- Right but he didn't
have to stay in California
to deal with all of that so
he's doing that back home
and like I said I talked to him
right before we came in here
and he said he was in a meeting.
- Yeah.
- With some guys
and that he was doing something tonight
so he's like--
- Probably Ned, Ted, and Fred.
- Oh yeah.
- The brother summit.
- But sending Lewis my love,
my father-in-law.
(Rhett sighs)
And,
I don't know, thank
you for hearing me out,
I don't know, take from it what you will.
I know I've taken a
lot from the experience
and I'm grateful to
have had it even though
it was in no way easy.
I feel very grateful for the
outcome for him and for Mom.
- Thank you for sharing, Link.
- Oh, you're welcome.
- We'll close with a quick rec.
I'm going to recommend another podcast.
Podcast that I've been
listening to that we are
in no way affiliated
with but I really like
called Science Versus.
It is a approximately
half hour, weekly podcast
where they very simply
take a subject of any kind.
It might be like climate change,
it might be DNA, hereditary companies,
it might be vaccines.
It might be gun control,
it's basically just issues
that people throw all
kinds of opinions out.
- Uh-huh.
- And they say,
we're only going to talk about
what the latest science is
and they do upwards of 100 resources
or references in each podcast.
It's very well researched, half hour,
and if you're the kinda person who's just
an inquisitive mind and you
wanna know what the science says
about a particular thing,
you can just scroll through.
They already addressed a
lot of different subjects
and keep coming out with weekly episodes
so Science Versus, recommended.
- Is it V-S or V-E-R-S-U-S?
- It's just V-S.
- Okay, easier.
There you have it, another
Ear Biscuit in the can!
#EarBiscuits, let us know if
any part of this conversation
or the experience I shared
resonates with you in any way.
I'd love to hear it
from you, #EarBiscuits.
And we'll speak at you again next week
because--
- That's what we do.
- Well that's what we plan on doing.
- Weekly, yeah.
We plan on it.
- I'm just sayin',
I don't know what life
could throw at us but--
- True.
- If it all lines up, we'll
bring another biscuit your way.
- Yep.
- [Link] To watch more Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist on the right.
- [Rhett] To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist to the left.
- [Link] And don't forget to click
on the circular icon to subscribe.
- [Rhett] If you prefer
to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your Mythical best.
(electronic music)